sometimes man these guys don't know what
they have so I I want to try and start
getting in more into talking about comic
books and what I do or don't like about
comic books on this channel more it kind
of kicked it off we're talking about
some comic book tropes that I can't
stand now we're going to talk about
something that exists in comics that I
actually like quite a bit but they also
don't really do anymore
so this serves as both a praise and a
complaint all bundled in one ha ha I I
can have layers or you know I just can't
not complain about things in any case
I'm gonna talk about legacy superheroes
now let's get some terminology out of
the way first
so a legacy superhero is someone who has
taken up the mantle of a hero who held
that mantle before them now this is
different from alternate versions this
is different from clones it's different
from anything like that so you know when
we're talking about legacy characters
you know the various clones of
spider-man those are not lacey versions
of a character someone like Miles
Morales is so that's sort of what I'm
talking about here
now legacy heroes kind of got kicked off
in many ways by accident
by DC because the sort of kick in the
butt for the entire Silver Age of comics
if you don't know there's the SIL the
Golden Age Silver Age Bronze Age and
then the suppose we're still considering
ourselves to be in the modern age except
the modern has been going on since the
80s I don't know if they figured out
something to transition it to the reboot
era I don't know but in any case what
kicked off the Silver Age in many ways
was the introductions of Hal Jordan as
the Green Lantern and Barry Allen is the
flash both of these were heroes that had
existed prior to this
the flash was originally Jay Garrick and
the Green Lantern was originally Alan
Scott but what DC did was they brought
in new versions using the same name
having similar powers in the case of
green lantern I'm gonna hold a backstory
but it brought in this idea of okay the
name of the hero we're gonna keep
because people know that and they like
it but we're gonna put somebody else in
that costume they're gonna have a
different thing going for them and that
continued on from there and I think by
and large DC did it best and I think it
was partly because they just kind of
stumbled into it it wasn't necessarily
by design for a lot of it and then as
time went along there was a lot more
legacy characters as as DC sort of moved
its way forward obviously there were a
lot more Green Lantern's Barry Allen
eventually died during crisis on
Infinite Earths to be replaced by Wally
West
Batgirl ended up becoming a legacy
character when Barbara Gordon became
paralyzed and the mantle of Batgirl got
taken up by somebody else and in general
what I like about legacy characters is
it allows you for a few things the first
thing it allows you for clear sectioning
off of different eras of a character
because any character that's been around
for a long time generally there's gonna
be different eras and by and large you
have to kind of section them off by
creative team problem with that is you
know creative teams can sometimes have
be very short-lived you know so short
that you wouldn't even call you know
some writers times on a character an era
you know you barely call it a run so
doing it by a span especially if you're
not a hardcore comics fan you know you
might not even know the writer off the
top of your head half the time so that
it's possible to section off by writer
and there's a validity to that but I
think there's an ease of sectioning
things off by who's holding the mantle
of that particular
character and the other and the reason I
like that is because as I'm getting
older I'm finding myself I'm finding it
harder to continue to find the joy in
comic books and it's not for some like
stupid book start as good as they were
when I was reading them I was reading
them in the 90s they weren't great then
but what what's hard for me to get too
far into a lot of comics these days I'll
still read them but I'm much more apt to
pick up something that is new for a
character I've never read before than I
am you know the latest issue of a
character that I've loved for a long
time and the reason for that is I've
come to really appreciate kind of the
necessity of story's ending and you know
certainly individual story arcs will end
but the longer characters go on the more
it feels like well there's no end to
this story and it can oftentimes sort of
take the stakes out of things and I
don't mean in a oh we know the hero's
gonna live way we always know the hero's
gonna live
except when they make a stupid event out
of it and kill them in the background
needlessly and blood alee so what I mean
is that having some finality means that
the decisions and the choices matter the
big problem with how long these
characters are ongoing is how much of
their development either of them as
characters or of their lives eventually
gets undone and reverses some of the
stuff I've talked about in my tropes
that I hate video stuff gets undone and
people aren't allowed to be happy and a
podcast in front of mine guy by the name
of Andrew Leyland he has a pod hit while
he has two podcasts is he has one he
does with a song called hey kids comics
they only do a couple of those a year
now back catalogs great though if you
want to listen to that and his own show
is a palace of glittering delights and
he talked about how he thought amazing
spider-man
99 would have been a really good last
issue for spider-man and I found myself
thinking about that a lot because on the
one hand the idea that Spiderman was
over that's kinda like well I love
spider-man I don't want him to be over
but then at the same time I think about
all the crap that the character has been
put through over the years to keep
undoing his progress
dialing him back obliterating his
marriage you know the the crap that gets
heaped onto him how many times his Aunt
May died and been brought back again and
again and again nothing sticks and I
think the way that you get around that
without having to retire the character
is through the use of legacy characters
so that you can have the the hero
continue but you can have the character
have closure have an ending happy or
tragic but for me knowing that these
stories are never gonna properly end
becomes exhausting and I just think
legacy characters are a fantastic way
around that as I said they don't do them
as much as they used to Marvel has
started to kind of try and do them
lately with mixed results but I'm gonna
come back to that first let's get back
to DC because like said for a long time
legacy characters were kind of a DC
thing and then the new 52 happened and
there's a lot that I hate about the new
52 if you don't know a ton about comic
books new 52 was a reboot of the
universe that and it lasted for about
five years before they reach igger the
thing again with an event called rebirth
that was I don't know two years ago now
I can't keep track
in any case new 52 hit the reset button
and more specifically brought back what
were considered by the editorial staff
at the time to be the iconic
versions of the characters meaning that
and some of this have been set up ahead
of time but it meant that Barbara Gordon
was Batgirl again
it meant that Hal Jordan was the Green
Lantern again meant that Barry Allen was
the flash again and on paper that sounds
fine but in many ways it's a big middle
finger to a chunk of the readership
because some of these characters had
been holding these Mantle's for decades
but all of a sudden no we're going back
to this one from when the writer and the
editors were kids that they think of as
the proper one we're bringing that one
back Wally West doesn't exist anymore
and it's it's it was a crappy thing to
do I mean it was it was awful
honestly in terms of treating your fans
and acting like you're doing them a
favor by wiping out stuff that they
liked and cared about another podcasting
friend of mine the irredeemable shagged
he's a huge fan of firestorm that's
actually his Twitter firestorm fan he
and it for him because it's what he grew
up breathing firestorm is Ronnie Raymond
and professor Stein the thing was that I
remember one a podcast where I don't
know if he had if he actually realized
it on air it sounded like you might have
but his his version of firestorm that he
thought of as this is firestorm Ronnie
had been part of firestorm for a shorter
stretch of time then then Jax was
afterwards meaning the guy that in his
mind was the Pretender to the throne had
held that mantle for for longer had more
right two cups of firestorm really and
but I think that's a that's a good way
to go about it because you can you can
as you want to with your person who's
taking up the mantle it becomes I'm not
going to say completely Oh
okay to revisit story points because you
don't want to get repetitive but it
becomes less egregious to do so and you
can revisit some of those themes some of
those events you know you can call back
to without literally putting the same
character through the same things again
now start about Marvel so like I said DC
kind of blew up the good thing that they
had and didn't appreciate Marvel really
didn't do legacy characters for a long
time they would do like short term
substitute hero stories every now and
then like there was a substitute Captain
America for the course of a story for a
while and other people have taken up the
mantle since since then you know Sam
Wilson was Captain America for a little
bit I think Bucky was Captain America
for a little bit but those those aren't
really legacy characters because they're
not they're not expected to maintain the
mantle for very long it's just for the
course of whatever story's currently
being told usually it's reversed within
a year so Marvel has tried and I don't
know if this is conscious on this part
if they like saw that DC blew up their
whole legacy thing and Marvel went ooh
can we start to fill that niche I don't
know if it was conscious or not but
they've tried to do it more recently and
unfortunately I think the fact that
Marvel didn't use to do it has been part
of why fans haven't taken to it in some
cases so some examples of legacy
versions for Marvel they did what I
think she still is they have a new Thor
and they have or they had I think they
finally brought Wolverine back from the
dead
or maybe they're about to again I can't
keep track anymore but there was a new
Wolverine and you know they they've done
some of these sometimes it's quite
significant step ins and you know these
these people taking up the mantle now I
don't want to get
into the argument of how the fact that
often these are radically different
characters in both the two that I that I
cited in the case of Wolverine and of
Thor they were taking Mantle's
previously held by male characters and
giving them two female characters I
don't want to get into to that end of it
because that kind of becomes a mess but
I do think at least an element of some
people's reluctance to go along with
this is the fact that this just isn't
something Marvel does and so Marvell
readers weren't really prepped for the
idea of no that's not Thor anymore this
is Thor now and I think inherently they
were always going to resist that at
least to a certain extent because the
most notable time that Marvel tried to
do legacy characters prior to the last
decade or so was in 90s again with
spider-man and a little mess called the
Clone Saga and I'm not gonna rehash all
this here but one of the things I was
supposed to happen was the clone of
spider-man who at least for a brief
stamp was supposed to be revealed to be
the actual original version and Peter
was the clone they reversed that later
but Ben character Ben Riley was meant to
take up the mantle of spider-man and on
paper that was actually not a bad idea
because the writers were many of the
writers again calling back to my own
video on tropes I can't I can't stand
many writers were feeling frustrated by
Peter Parker's home life and the fact
that he had a wife and you know that
felt like too much stability and they
and you know they wanted to write
classic swinging single Peter Parker and
the the idea of having Peter retire to
go off and have his happy life with his
wife and finally be able to hang up you
know the mask and have been right I take
it over on paper honestly I think it's a
tease an idea they blew it on so many
levels introducing the idea that
was actually the original Peter Parker
and Peter was the clone that was a
stupid idea because that that pissed
readers off because it made them feel
like wait you're telling me we haven't
even been following the real Peter
Parker for the last 20 30 years now that
screwed up so you know that that was a
stupid idea they should have just
admitted from the beginning no Ben is a
is a clone and you know Peter isn't
going to vanish and never appear again
but he's not gonna be spider-man anymore
we're gonna let him have a happy ending
but I get the Clone Saga story was such
a mess I mean the end result was a
disaster and the writing of it it was
supposed to I think last a year it
dragged on years and years and years and
they didn't know where they were going
with it and there's so many things that
went nowhere or just it was it was a
complete and total crapshoot and I think
that also soured Marvel fans on the idea
of legacy characters now has Marvel done
legacy characters well yes I actually
think they have possibly the most
successful legacy character of modern
times which is Kamala Khan as Ms marvel
and that one they actually got really
lucky in a way because the the classic
miss marveled Carol Danvers had been
basically promoted for lack of a better
term to Captain Marvel she took up that
mantle and that actually left the mantle
of MS Marvel unoccupied and these were
not connected things they didn't move MS
Marvel into taking the mantle of Captain
Marvel in order to allow Kamala Khan to
become Miss Marvel they were unconnected
and so when Kamala Khan stepped into the
mantle of MS Marvel it felt much more
organic it didn't feel like they were
forcibly rejiggering things it felt more
like they went oh you know what since we
took Carole and we did this with her we
could have somebody else do this yeah
let's do that and it had a much more
organic feel to it because it was it was
a void that stood to be filled as
opposed to any feeling of elbowing out
whoever was currently there in order to
bring in somebody new because that's
that's oftentimes the complaint I see
now when people when any you know
whether it's the movies or the comic
books or even fans just propose the idea
of bringing in a new Legacy version of a
character or you know and whether it's a
brand new character an established
character who's gonna take up the mantle
it's not uncommon for fans to go look if
you want a new character a new hero just
make a new character or a new hero why
do you have to mess with the ones that
are there but I'm gonna come back to the
two what I said at the beginning I think
there's a satisfaction in bringing a
story to a close that again I can't
speak for everybody but I can speak for
me and I can say eventually it's
distancing and alienating and yeah it
kind of saps away my desire to keep
reading comics knowing that this
characters gonna be doing this forever
and knowing that one day they can stop
ideally with a happy ending but for
whatever reason one day they can stop
and somebody reading after me gets to
have their own spider-man a Wolverine
Superman Batman whatever that they can
have their version that is dares it's
got nothing to do with me and I don't
even feel the need to wag my finger at
them like you're doing spider-man wrong
he wasn't like that was like well no but
that's not Peter Parker
that's Miles Morales so that's you know
that's whoever you go oh oh well my
version was better and fine be grumpy
and have that but you you won't have to
wired your finger at them anymore
because they're not screwing up your
character they just gave someone else a
chance to do what they could do with
that
and I I can't help but feel that the
heyday of legacy characters
is is come and gone and we are now in an
age where like like I said DC just threw
out what they had and Marvel seems to
have trouble finding the balance between
doing something new and exciting and not
taking off the fan base for one reason
or another and it's a shame because I
think it's one of the potentials of
superhero comic books that was there for
a little bit and has kind of been left
to drift off and fade away and those are
my thoughts on legacy superheroes what I
like about them why I wish they were
being used more and my thoughts on a few
of the examples that I could think of
off the top of my head there are way
more than I brought up trust me so what
are your thoughts on legacy heroes do
you have a personal favorite character
where you like a later version of the
character that came along as opposed to
the original or you want to name a
legacy character where they totally
screwed it up on the on the new person
who took the mantle whatever your
thoughts are drop something down in the
comments let's talk about it there's a
whole bunch of stuff to do I think you
know what it is you smart you've been
around here cuz you know there's buttons
and there's links and stuff there's a
patreon link and you know check that out
if you want to so remember folks you're
the council I just run the meetings then
until next time this council is
adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]